ok people are entering the torture
device that is Metallica that beautiful
sound wooden roller coasters by the way
in this game I can't get over that as
awesome sound design even though it is
not realistic it is so nostalgic and
this is real GCI action over here this
is our to add that in the in the name
made by GC I thought that makes all the
oath at is not that is not how brackets
work that is not how brackets work
either excuse me I have an American
keyboard and I am European and I don't
know how to how to work with American
keyboard settings and every time it
resets to American keyboard settings but
oh well that this is an awesome ride and
now all of the coast of nerds you can
are gonna go on it because it says made
my GC so that's going to be good this
coaster is still looking strong too I
mean by that I mean a roller coaster and
I think it's time for a topspin because
we don't have enough puke on the paths
yet I can definitely be a bit more so we
needed topspin so that's what you want
that thing for and this seems like the
perfect location except the terraforming
is not really perfect now in roller
coaster tycoon one unless roller coaster
second two ups you have you actually
have the hill terraforming tool or
whatever this thing is supposed to be
called but this little tool over here
and that is amazing because this tool is
the best seriously I don't know why they
removed this in roller coaster tycoon 2
but it's awesome so yes thank you for
inventing this and make this platform
just a tiny bit bigger and what why why
oh oh oh I'm stupid there is a bush over
there and there's a bush over there too
and that should be good now let's see
I'm going to take the top spin and we're
gonna place this tennis move somewhere
question is where feel like this would
actually be good but only if i add that
little thing over there
okay there we go and the topspin it's
going to be a the entrance is gonna be
over here the exit will be here and over
there and no I can just build a bridge
like that kind of don't have to bother
actually terraforming the land to make
that look better because I think that
looks okay as is the queue however i'm
going to kind of work into this hill
because i just seems like a fun idea
that i want to give a shot and thank you
now 1q and now we're done here very good
the color scheme as of now is absolutely
ridiculous oh this this thing is called
a graviton in this game I completely
forgot that I keep forgetting that every
single time but this color scheme
however is unexcusable we're gonna have
to have this kind of thing actually no
other shade of green or perhaps another
caller entirely perhaps this this shade
of red hmm so even that bad and blue
okay that that is completely stupid if I
make it orange the orange is kind of too
bright in this game even that kind of
oil orange is still a bit too bright and
the yellow again is too yellow I feel
like this would actually be my best bet
yeah i'm just going to do it like that
and now i'm going to play some small
trees around it simply because you know
you sometimes you just need some scenery
ish things and that's in the shape of
foliage over here that lies overkill
don't wanna have that i need some small
shrubs because my shrubbery and I think
we're done here we just need a these
trees because these things are beautiful
seriously
not too many people use these things i
think but they are amazing and there we
go and this area does have a terrible
lack of ground shrubbery but also normal
trees I'm actually going to play some of
these rappers which are called the red
first but everybody just sees them as
the template kind of trees in this game
because this is the country that you
have in every single park everywhere the
cross is still mowing over there which
is kind of stupid I definitely don't
want to bend an entire supports because
oh wow there is one small Bush over
there we best protect that and some over
here and I think I'm almost done almost
just died couple of small bushes over
here guys of course that is not enough
memory because there is never enough but
that's just a certain point where you
have to stop so yeah I do think this
looks pretty cool aside from the crazy
amount of vomit on the paths here I'm
going to just assign one guy over here
because it seems that either this roller
coaster is a sec making machine or the
maze that i created is a sigma making
machine and i don't think it's the maze
or the monorail or the bumper cars so i
am pretty sure who to blame over here
though looking at this monstrosity i am
not too surprised still beautiful though
um sound also pretty amazing I have to
stop myself from just looking at
something the entire time and not doing
anything else I need to work on the pike
I suppose but then again it's a really
anything to work on right now money is
flowing in like crazy as you can see not
and I don't have too much land to buy
anymore just over here but they're
already roller coasters over there so
that is not going to really work out
could possibly play something over there
but then again the other issue is that i
don't have too many rides left just the
whoa
and nothing else really because all
these things are inferior and stuff that
I don't like to use no I could I could
somehow get the world Bally over here
the question is how am I going to do
that so far though I think I do like the
pipe layout and especially this new area
I'm a pretty big fan of that but this
area is still somewhat empty aside from
the roller coaster of course but there
are no attractions yet there are people
walking everywhere thinking that there's
something to find over here but they'll
find that there is nothing to find can I
do that it seems almost too close to the
pike border to actually be able to do
that and I can't buy any line over there
which is a which is a shame so it seems
like the only option I have at this
point is to actually buy more land over
here you know what I am just going to do
that this is going to be my new area
please welcome your new Lord and Master
don't have enough cash for that this is
pretty expensive I am running out of
money I don't have any more alone um how
much money do I still have left 4,000
euros that should be just about as
enough to actually built this ride and
do some stuff with it these trees are
almost too colorful to be realistic
seriously it's and a weird
now I'm gonna have some of that new path
work over here as well I'm going to move
that there however I see some broken
benches and i need to replace those
things anything else over here there you
are and I don't see anything over here
but I'm wondering why I didn't place any
benches over there because that is
that's quite stupid that's my eating
area that should definitely have benches
think of a call about those things and
some more over here now people are
making a mess of this pike i'm going to
have even more handyman I'd rather pay
all these salaries for all these handy
man than having a bike that looks like a
[ __ ] stone say this area is not
looking to about though and this area is
however this guy is assigned to that
little roller coaster over there this
guy is assigned to this area and even
though I've one guy for just this area
it still manages to be a crap area
that's beautiful now here is going to be
my newest attraction mmm no actually no
no no I'm going to move that two squares
like that
you know as unserious as it might sound
sometimes I'm very serious about the
look of my Park and no kind of
constantly checking whether everything
is looking good like this area doesn't
really have too many trees yet still has
some bare spots from this angle so I
want to work on that funny how people
actually using the monorail even though
it's completely pointless over here and
really just there for aesthetic reasons
and let's see let's get an entrance and
an exit for this thing that is that is
the wrong side why do I keep doing that
that is the right side oh my god are the
music of the ferris wheel just the
fairest way I mean the carousel just
slowly slows down as it crashes which is
fun though it's not as fun though as
when it crashes and speeds up and starts
launching people everywhere that's when
the music goes crazy and now this thing
is called tower that's a pretty
impressive name I'm going to keep that
no need to change your winning team and
I'm going to test it like this yeah that
does it it can definitely be a bit
faster oh you know actually I'm going to
make the tower is slightly smaller go to
remove a couple of those things and see
how this works yeah I think that's fine
and I'm good to make this thing look
that is that is weird it's good to keep
the standard color scheme for some some
of these rides these standards color
scheme just seems to be the best color
scheme and whether that whether that's
because of the fact that they always
come with that color scheme and that
just seems like the right thing to do or
thanks to the fact that it just looks
best I don't know but it's a fact and I
can't get around it and a couple of
trees and then I think we're already
done in this area it wasn't really too
much to work on
some cool trees over here but that's
pretty much it I think we're done we can
open the tower we can ask 370 which is
quite a lot for two stupid launches on a
metal pole but whatever i think i am
very much afraid that this is going to
be the the final stage of the pike this
is what it's going to look like when i
finish this scenario let me save that
specific saving yes that was rat Robin I
i changed the sounds of my computer
don't blame me and let's see there's
nothing else to do no research to be
done yup it's doing the right
improvements and you know as soon as
it's doing the right improvement you
know there's nothing useful to research
anymore though it still has roller
coasters we could look at what roller
coasters we might still get which we
can't do anything with but you know I
can look at it and I'm actually making
profit Wow learning quite a bit of money
over here people are actually riding
these shipwrecks again so that's good
and I still like the look of this thing
and once again it might be nostalgia but
just the track the supports I can't even
explain it it's just so awesome and by
that i mean the co co type not this ride
this ride is completely the poop now
that lies not spoon it to negatively
it's okay for what it does being a
junior coaster
and for some reason I like this this
type of attraction more when it has just
a couple of cars rather than a long
string of nine cars per train but then
again that might also be nostalgia
because Diamond Heights has these small
cars and I mean the small trains and I
don't know when that park is coming up
it's either in one or two maps I don't
know by heart anymore but I'm already
looking forward to diamond heights
because that is the park and I don't
know how this thing is doing but not too
many people were entering it but it's
making a somewhat steady profit so
that's good and I still like the look of
it it could use some more fencing though
he's gonna add a small fence over here
just kind of zone that off and
especially on the back side it could
still use a fence or something like that
so I'm going to place that there we go
and I think we don't know how did I not
even finish that right yet I'm starting
to think that I can actually maintain
this ride with just one train and I mean
that wouldn't be too efficient but not
that many people were entering right now
so i might wanted to know actually
looking at how many people were entering
it right now that would mean always half
the capacity that it currently has so
definitely not a great idea and these
things are not a great idea either just
kind of random looking over there I
wanted to do something with them but you
know they didn't really work so i might
want to find a special area where i can
build some fountains you know i'm going
to try that over here some shrubs in the
way but that doesn't matter that does
not stop me
see if I can buy my land over here yeah
i'm just going to do that because it
looks better and then i'm going to add a
small torture device over here this is
going to be the Chinese torture device
fountain in the middle of course and
then on the sides we can have that fun
water stuff that you wouldn't want to
have but for some reason makes the
excitement rating of rides around it
higher because oh wow as a waiter low
price and this is for 60 which was 440
so that's an improvement though I doubt
that's because of the fountains rather
it's because of the path work and stuff
like that I thought that's too much of
those trees way are you too much I'm
just going to use those small ones it's
too many of those you know I think I
feel like that is good cup of shrubs and
we're done here time to mow the entire
park just make it look a bit better bits
idea hopefully I am NOT going to
accidentally raise one spot because that
would be a true nightmare and the only
real risk of doing this is when you
accidentally move your mouse when you're
clicking and you raise the land and you
screw everything over it's certainly not
as bad as in roller coaster tycoon 3 but
still it's pretty terrible right now how
is Metallica doing and it's making 8000
just about 8,000 a yacht I never really
expected this thing to be too efficient
I mean it's incredibly huge but mostly
it's it might probably be a good visitor
attractor that thing at least I am sure
it would attract visitors
this area is looking pretty not that
interesting but this is kind of like
this is a sloped area so it's not really
anything anyway where you can do
interesting stuff just kind of there and
sometimes open areas can do wonders for
your park and look a lot better than
when they were example for example
filled with the rides sometimes you just
need an open area don't mow the grass
don't ever do that how many days do we
have left until okay it's currently the
13 and you know what you know what I
could do if I if I have the time for it
anyway um I figured like I could like
take a quick look through the park look
at what we've made we have Don McLean's
right over here which is a beautiful
ferris wheel we have the beautiful Jose
gallopers was that name even based on
this is the kind of starting area you
can clearly tell by the fact that
there's only flat rides and of course
their junior coaster but I don't know if
that is really credit which is
shipwrecked by the awesome alestorm song
we have tower and exquisite churner
depth I hate myself sometimes here is
limewire because you are a pirate this
thing is just called haunted house that
that was underwhelming as of course mine
mania which I do really like and it's
stupid that it's raining because now you
can't really see it all that well and oh
oh oh I did I did I made a grave mistake
I'm going to heart I'm going to have to
recolor that now we go mine menya is
restored then we have the monorail which
is also an under and the maze and the
bumper cars of one that's that's just
got rid of the one not as as not a good
thing metallica made by GCI and the
roller coaster she's still really like
even though this is the kind of thing
that I always do in leave
like I always place a looping kosu along
this edge because there's nothing else
you can really do with it but every
single time it just it's just looping
roller coaster with either one or two
looping xand some fun stuff around it
every time it's a slightly different one
but still it's the same thing every
single time I don't know if you guys
ever have that with one park but often I
I do very similar things in the same
spot of a park and i have used this area
for a wooden roller coaster before but
that was a terrible feel that was more
like a the storm wooden roller coaster
which we like go up a lot over here and
then do some carts and coaster
shenanigans over here and then have a
twisty part here and some kind of
station area here but that wasn't quite
as i wasn't quite as happy with that
wooden roller coaster as i am with this
one and thank heavens it started it
stopped raining and it's the 24th of
october right now i don't think there's
anything else to really work on I could
work on some small things like adding a
fence over here nothing made you know
it's still cool and some of these things
over here this area still seems like it
needs more benches so i'm going to i'm
just going to deliver and i think that's
it
this area is nice and tidy as is really
going to change anything about that when
you have a beautiful little plaza with
flowers and a fountain in the middle and
stuff like that it doesn't really seem
like you need too much decorations
around that because your or this this
thing in the middle is already the
center of attention and you're
definitely not going to want to draw the
attention away with other things and you
know it's just going to be one big look
at me fast with the scenery and is that
any right we missed yeah we have the the
slide this is this is extremely table
and there is the Gravitron hmm yes life
was sure good when I was actually still
trying with my name's for attractions
now what I should again start trying
with names for attractions but before I
do that I'm going to add a hedge over
here I don't have enough hedges in this
park yet see that is beautiful that is
true beauty
actually do like that yeah there we go
yes ok I'll I just silver yeah I suppose
I'm silver so that was leafy lake thank
you for watching and in the next episode
we're gonna do hanan I me let me save
the game um and um to new game and it is
diamond heights yes so we're gonna do
diamond heights so i'll see you all then